this is the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz
today I'm in Manchester I'm joined by
Coyle Winterbottom who is an associate
director for Laurence Harvey and for
those that can't see me the magic it's a
short sleeve shirt and a very flowery
top so I think let's start there man why
the hell are you in there
this a time mate yeah great question
right so it was off the back of a really
cool incentive that we decided to set to
to Blackpool kind of the back end of h1
to h2 incentive and yeah you've picked
to interview me on the dead that we're
doing the same day that goes with that
so this the club or that you're going to
be wearing a black ball absolutely not I
mean look I've got me got me flip-flops
yes thank you for joining me for this
and as I'm just saying that where I
always like to start
how did Kyle enter the world of
recruitment mate taught to me I guess
it's probably very similar to to a lot
of people make to be honest with you so
we lived out in the US and worked in
played football out there on a
scholarship I kind of did an amazing
what's that Charlotte North Carolina
okay one of my close friends did that
and he did it in had that experience
yeah so I just went over there and like
a two-year program to get a masters
degree did that play football for two
years it came out of there was a little
like good football wise yeah we had some
so I mean probably shouldn't say this
because it's probably going some
regulations but like x.x england spain
not under 18 players and captains and
it's still very much
you still got do you educate like that
still disappear you rate you're a
student athlete yeah that's the thing
okay yeah what Edition do play center of
the center forward and you know Scott
bigger and slower so
nice no did you did you get any
opportunity in the UK to play a football
anything like that or that's normally
the part right or even in America yes so
very early on I mean very early on so
aged 10 and I was kind of in and around
the scene of a few local kind of left
pro clubs mainly Mon United but it was
very brief stint more and more in the
kind of I guess you know trialing
environment it's funny said we were
talking I was in there when I was last
working in the hunted offices I'm gonna
chat with there and Joe Mela there and
we were just talking about football and
stuff and we're saying how like you will
always hear someone say yeah when I was
eight years old after all of that you
know prosody denied me yeah played a
plate of a few games for them and stuff
but you know in an official that
offseason that didn't work out you know
no sob story didn't happen football in
happened you know age 12 I had four
operations to remove a kidney so really
yeah that was why that didn't happen
that's America this is still and how I'd
use you at that point so I finished
University in England went over to
America so I have been old have been 21
o market so I did two years there to
really gave it a go yes and yeah fully
committed and then and then was there
was there a point where you lie actually
it's not gonna happen
yeah I mean like you when when you're
playing over there you you know you're a
student first you and I'm a second it's
just you know you play football to pay
your way basically you know so the
university effectively pays for your
studies over there you know it was a
smaller private school so the the
tuition fees were pretty expensive so I
got the bulk of that paid for yeah
which was good you know set me in good
stead and then I went into I guess I was
trying to find a job that I sponsored me
for a visa because that's a big issue
out there obviously no experience so
into I guess one of these pyramid type
schemes like it was b2b so selling
I guess we were an outsourced sales
office for Staples you know the offices
it was like territorial based yeah just
what my mate did this my mate did this
but we're selling lawn mowers yeah yeah
that's mad so there's no it was a steep
learning curve mate but I think
obviously yeah you mean you just walking
into businesses mate with you know you
had a scripts that you'd learn and you
just set off going it was you know
really old schools he had a catalog you
have to take the router there and it was
no appointments you know it was you know
sales 101 yeah
you know I'm not coming back time thing
we've got a promotion and all that kind
of jazz and it really really really well
at that I earn a lot of money at a very
young age yeah well pokers the axon a
from the most in the south for the in
the south of the US with you know young
British lad with a of an accent kind of
coming in selling paper and pens and
printers that you know you need really
so absolute interns all the super where
you ended up okay
so then so you did that and then what
you ended up coming back to the UK yeah
came back home so it got to the point
where I guess I was working in in a
capacity where you like and on an
extension of your student visa yeah it's
a game work experience in you will and
then yeah came time for them to sponsor
me and there was a whole host of trouble
we've we've kind of that because I guess
the US immigration issue you're probably
aware you know you've got a justify why
you're given a job to a person when
there's a very capable American person
glad to do it so decided to pack up and
come back home and yeah I guess how I
got into recruitment was I was applying
for sales I've done really well in a
sales role out there just applying like
sales type roles they actually spoke to
a rhetoric who I felt I was interviewing
for yeah so end of the conversation I
was kind of like okay and it's not right
I'm gonna put you to a few of our
clients and I was like wow
that's actually that's actually Matt
that how often that happens okay so then
and then I'm assuming interviewed a few
places then you ended up at the renowned
yes free yeah yeah he was this 11 2011
year and that was in Manchester mm-hmm
okay cool and then just to sort of set
the scene then so you worked there for
how many years s3 and so it was about
four and a half years yeah and during
that period time really before that you
will see didn't just stay in the UK is
that right you went to Dubai yeah and
then after the boy went to America yeah
again and then after America came back
to UK yep and then also we're at this
point yeah I can make one I'm looking
forward to unpacking this mate yeah so
cool so foreign harmony in the s3 I
think obviously said before so that was
all contract with it yeah yeah okay so
we're we're always like to just get
people to start is because is that
there's sort of first as one of months
and how that was just because my own
experience is really difficult I'm sure
now when you've managed people and that
is a real difficult period yeah I mean I
guess for you you've you've been you
would have had that experience would
being punched in the mouth face to face
which would help right Fewster plus yeah
exactly
getting that rejection that must have
helped but how are your first five
months mate in the sort of s3 Manchester
environment initially really tough I
think obvious I'd come from a direct
sales role where you usually do in four
or five sales a day to an environment
where it's like you know it's better to
do one or two deals a month yeah so the
pace of it was as interesting yeah to me
was really slow yeah which now you know
I guess it's quite interesting because
obviously contractors in recruitment
terms typically fast pace or more fast
but yeah yeah but yeah to be honest we I
struggled what was the market so bi
contracts pretty much it all in that may
and the Oracle technologies okay
I was I was massively lucky I started
working at s3 for computer futures so I
was
tech brand and there was a great
management and leadership team there but
there was a few like serious heavy hairs
really good doing you know 10 12 14 15
grand a week like contrary villas that
you know you're just kind of sitting
listening to yeah you know whatever so
okay so why was it tough what did you
find that so you mentioned about the
pace that obviously that has an
adjustment but why did you find it so
tough early on I think one of the
biggest things for me obviously it
seemed um sales experience just being
able to influence people face to face
and how are you trying to do it over the
phone and I guess that was a reservation
when they interviewed you know they were
kind of saying to me you know you used
to be in front of people do you think
that of that'll kind of put you at
disadvantage if you know that the
talents like that I'll do this
I think first first six months I really
struggled that I didn't do a deal to mom
six really yeah and I was just you know
of one of them I was I was working I was
typically up there for top of the call
times top of the kpi status and was
coming off and nothing was coming off
and I think I remember my to this day my
manager was just kind of say look just
be patient like you do doing the right
thing it'll happen and we had a slight
switching market kind of a month four or
five and then one six it and didn't my
first deal and then it was like deal
deal deal yeah so I think the first six
months were super tough there were times
where I was like oh yeah I don't think
this is for me why did you continue then
that's just me miss marks yeah I just I
love to win and I hated in defeated so
yeah I think it was certainly that
element of it for me but it was more
more self competitive you know I kind of
couldn't probably a pride thing really
like I didn't want to kind of let myself
down by walking away you say that around
your was it your manager that said Carl
keep didn't we doing it's the right
activity the right work ethic it'll pay
off because I got that advice as well so
I mean I think my first deal in three
months but I had a [ __ ] first year mate
like I didn't bill a lot at all but he
kept saying to me he should keep them
will pay off blah blah blah and you were
sort of experience a bit of a tipping
point where things are start to click so
do you think that helped in terms of
knowing that the people around you said
car that you are doing for my things you
are doing their activities that you knew
though you I'm sure that helps you
believe that it is gonna happen whatever
and get get through it yeah absolutely I
think look I've never done McCrimmon
before so I really listening to what
people were telling me yeah you know
they were I think you know naturally s3
is an environment where this load of
good people and a lot of people make it
and there's some that don't and it's you
know so naturally I was kind of like you
know it's not quite clicking for me so
there's there's a lot of concern on that
from I think you know it was yeah
obviously it was nice to hear you know
yeah especially when these members of
the team mate literally smash it in 8/9
contract it was a month you know and you
and you're kind of sat there
soul-destroying
yeah but ended up that first year doing
on captain doing okay yes yeah so I
ended up going on the kind of incentive
trip I was like from the used to run the
competitions in like leagues at Budapest
yeah in in December
freezing but yeah no it was it was good
so I guess 1/6 you know month twelve but
you kind of just snowball and yeah I
kind of came into a year to with you
know about a four or five K contracts
okay yeah so before we move on very
quickly what I'd love to just get your
thoughts on through that experience so
my experience is Pam equipment right but
just quickly before we move up move on
thinking and people listening right now
who are early on in their contract
recruitment career what looking back now
what what do you think
so it took office either that six-month
period of you obviously having activity
and these types of things which
obviously is part of the
but what anything any advice around that
there's someone that's early on should
they be really dumping down on the I
don't know getting jobs in building
right relationships or I don't know
because I don't really understand the
complete nuances in the contract might
be a bit different like anything look I
think I would really look in that thus
out that we had s3 was you know we had a
super slick process really so for us you
know I remember our ratios in terms of
you know jobs pulled two jobs placed you
know we categorized other jobs yeah it
was it was stupidly high and I think
that was just down to a really slick
process you know so we had to have the
job signed off by management and all
that type of see yeah I mean that you
know it's a lot of people that probably
sounds like Jesus a bit on top but I
think that allowed us to you know know
that we could go and I could go and pull
you know a job a month that was my mind
saying I can go and pull a couple of
jobs a month probably going to fill them
you know so whereas you know I know from
my own experience sometimes where you
ratios are much higher than that you
know you might have to go and pull 810
jobs a month to do a couple of guess
that process enabled you to work right
off right absolutely
if you pull the job and then your mind
is like nah car light and how good this
information they're not committed so so
that whole process that means it yeah
the time you was bending yeah so then I
guess so just from what I'm
understanding sitting down with
contractor groups and stuff like is is
should people be that really buckling
down on pulling doors
cuz I feel like from one understand
sitting down with you busy obviously
candidate pieces I don't want to say
completely not easy but like it's easier
the crime piece that you really want to
try and double down on it's definitely
the client page so I think it's kind of
relationships and I guess when you get
the chat where you know when you get the
chance to deliver on a job deliver on it
delivered oh yeah because I think you
know my experience now I've you know
done some you know quite a lot of Perm
stuff over more recent years and I think
what I've realized is that typically you
know and this is a generalization but
you know typically hiring managers that
are hiring contractors they're not
really that bothered where they get them
from
it's kind of who complete is that
because it's because like they need like
they need them it's definitely an
urgency thing yeah for me you know I say
to the guys here all the time on on the
contract front it's like you know if you
get a job it's can you provide the best
candidates a competitive rate in a very
quick time frame and if you can cover
those boxes you know whether they like
one hard the probably you know they're
probably gonna use you which is
obviously massively different to the to
the perm bridge yeah interesting so okay
so got through that had a solid end of
your first obviously first year and so
when did you go to the by then 2014 okay
so you have the solid period in in
Manchester and what was like the typical
route was it just contract biller and
then did you manage anyone by the time
you left or yes senior consultant how
did that progress through the ranks up
to senior and all that type of stuff and
I think what s3 a really good at is you
know allowing you to do the job that you
want before you before you actually get
there in a sense you know so some people
look at that as a disadvantage but for
me that was kind of like a chance to
prove myself so what did I mean what did
you get the chance to do so obviously
you move through the ranks in terms of
you your title and natural that comes
with pay increasing about to have a
stuff but then chance to like really run
and manage your team without having the
title of being a team manager so so give
you those actually responsible yeah so I
remember the year that I moved to Dubai
would come back in in the January and we
were looking to kind of build a new team
the other way to trust me with that so
we had four trainees that died who said
look we'll give you them want you to run
at this go go healthful ever I guess you
know it was only a month or so later
that had the conversation about moving
to divide so but I still kind of
theoretically if you like manage on then
towards that you know those four people
which would obviously help them get put
in good stead when you went to the bank
not sorta okay so two things that before
we talk about your soul journey moving
abroad and stuff like that first one is
the business development piece so we're
just talking about their most common
thing I'll get asked about to ask people
about so during that period and I guess
you can touch on throughout your career
right so particularly in the contract
world as you said pulling jobs clients
that isn't really important how did you
how did you get better at that and then
the advice around that because that
that's definitely the most difficult
part that a lot of people find yeah I
think looking back on it now as a
contract recruiter for me it was just I
was I was probably very traditional in
the sense that for me it was just no
money yeah I was I was just confident
that I could make enough course to get
enough clients on the phone and once I
was got them on the phone I was half
decent enough to get something out of
that call and so for me it was just work
ethic but I think that's when we spoke
yeah it's weird change recently hundred
percent yeah you know the whole you know
work smart not hard piece I'm still need
to work out yeah this I think it
certainly changed and and even up until
really joining Lawrence Ave you know I
was still always of that kind of
mentality you know you see things about
personal branding social need you and
the marketing piece and I was just get
that but for me I can just click on the
phone and you know and that was always
the just the kind of way it was you me
but I guess we've had probably more
success than I've ever had
really yeah from a business development
piece I'm over the last 18 months by
changing the approach so let's talk
about that now there okay what have you
changed what's the work what whether you
realize mentally like hanging them in
their car in Manchester 2012-13 or
whatever just smashing the phones is
this not proven as as successful like
what life do you know I mean that much
been difficult to accept that yeah I
think that I've come with experience may
have experience in different cultures
and you know going to Dubai it was
massively relationship driven so you
know you could you could be the best
recruiter in the world the best video in
the world but if you didn't get out in
front of them it was a bit of a struggle
you know then I went to the US where it
was very much more of a search
environments and them stand processes
were
really really slow so I guess it had a
kind of a bit of a mixed bag when it
comes to the type of you know roles that
I was working the sets that work
approach difference I have people like
to approach them stuff yeah exactly so I
think one out when I started at Laurence
Harvey for me it was just like look I
know I can I know that I can do some you
know some some damage when I get on the
phone because that's mark that's biddies
always really been my strength yeah
probably because I'm a contractor grew
about trades yeah but I guess I was just
kind of sitting thinking about what
what's really going to allow me to get
more people on the phone you know rather
than just calling through switchboards
because we started here it was in pretty
much a new market for the business into
a brand new office new geography we've
had a few people in London working you
know here but you know pretty cold
market switchboard absolutely hi there
my name's John get through actually my
name's Karl sorry about that yeah this
is what I do that typical stuff yes so
you know I guess I'm very methodical in
my approach I need to be able to see
right okay who's the target client use
the hire imagine that client yeah Wow
nothing about and then it was just like
what's gonna allow me to get them on the
phone and I think we've got a we're
looking here we've got a wicked
marketing team and they do a lot of
events so they were kind of leaning on
me a little bit saying look gone gone
see what's out and about they're from an
event perspective isn't something that
you can speak to these people about and
I kind of run with that idea or it's a
different approach I'll give it a go see
what happens and and lo and behold it it
kind of worked you know and there were a
lot more clients answering the phone
clients coming to me saying you know so
what was the actual experience because
that must have been like hey what is it
so literally
the great thing about that is that we'll
see it never used to stay on the phone
but it was received totally different
she wasn't yeah it's just the approach
most so it's just you know it was it was
a non recruitment related call but kind
of naturally with anything I knew that
if I could get these people on the phone
I was speaking to them about how we
could add value by
in an event on that might not you know
that might be lacking in the space and
then you know naturally most of the time
you know you're on the phone with them
for 30 45 minutes talking about who you
are what you do yeah I'd say 7 out of 10
calls that I would make you know again
actually we're looking for this can you
help really yeah what well I wanted to
come and meet you anyway to speak about
the event let's just wrap it all up
there and yeah and and I was just kind
of like you know I've been doing this
run for the last six years yeah so okay
just just to finalize that cuz I think a
lot of people may be thinking well I'm
not I'm a recruiter like I'm not a
[ __ ] event events creator I'm not
creative all these things right so like
these types of phone calls is it I mean
it's not rocket science it pretty much
involved the typical type of approach
but then you're talking about sort of
the the event or an event idea that you
may have are you open to getting
involved this is why thinking about
starting there blah blah blah and then
just using that whole conversation to
maybe at some point but I'm assuming you
don't go with the intention of giving
them a sales picture of what Lawrence
Harvey do that just sort can happen
quite naturally you know I mean but is
it a lot how different was it because
some people might be listening though a
bit that'll be a bit weird calling up
people and talking about events you know
I mean I don't think personally but I
think it's funny you ask that question
because when I sit with our head of
marketing and we're talking about you
know this and I guess we've created a
bit of a community here around this
event series that's snowballed into
something bigger than I ever thought it
would yeah and I guess for me that just
has come a little bit natural I guess
I'm still a little bit unsure of what
the kind of barriers are for people but
it was very much a case of look here's
who Lawrence that Muse is what I'm doing
is my role in the business yeah and
here's the reason that I'm calling you
and yeah it's at that point that it was
like you know we want to put an event on
we're big in the event space as a
recruitment business but to be honest
with you we don't just want to put
something on for the sake of it yeah
Frank give some value wallow add
something back so what do you feel is
missing and then you know I'd kind of
take all the feedback from that call and
roll it into the next you know I've just
go out to John Smith it's such a body
yeah he said this what do you think
about now yeah I agree and then and then
that concept of you know I guess we've
created the day
the north community that that came off
the back of you know yeah this is not a
great deal in terms of an intimate
roundtable type of event there's a lot
of meetups and world in tech type stuff
but from a leadership perspective people
that head up date are eliminated science
functions you know I've got travel to
London it's two days at the office it's
actually on the train and the hotel and
so we kind of roll with it and on Lanai
so I think that anyone listening one I
think and if you feel if you're good on
my phone which please you will be if
you're good at building relationships
like like back yourself and and you'll
love with the process which usually
they'd use what you've you've done in
terms of yeah the typical beauty that
you've you've done and and I mean what's
the worst that can happen right like do
not be I think if I look back over
everything you know throughout all the
different types of recruitment I've done
in terms of the different roles the
different sectors
the thing that's allowed the most
success has been meeting people meaning
people you know that's as3 they were big
they were big on that you know because
obviously you want to try and wrap got a
contract client so opposites you know
get in front of them if you place in
with them go and say come out for a
lunch or whatever the case may be and
you know like when I started here is
very much a case of well let me cover
media we're going to talk about the
event the other naturally you know one
of the biggest challenges they have this
talent because it's not a client shot
market so they start asking you for
advice and before you know it you pretty
much you know you know ingrained in
their business somewhat really and I
realize okay cool so the other thing
when I just wanted to talk to him which
I'm always curious about because I've
had a few people's who worked to esperan
stuff in you and you said there at the
beginning around like you you could see
a live work he was really exposed to
some like big hitters right what were
the tip what are the typical things you
saw in these people the sort of you
thing enabled them to looking back now
whatever like what was some of the
common things that you notice in them
that and they would them to absolutely
clear cuz I'm sure it would still work
now I'll have an impact now yeah I think
you know back in but back in you know
the s3 days and think about all the
people that were really big pillars that
was lucky enough to learn from I think
to be honest with you whose worker
really it was just work ethic and and
tenacity you know and it was there's
people in there that we're running 14 15
grand a week GP contract books that were
still there at nine o'clock at night and
you know just chasing down leads and
specking in CVS and you just ER
I guess they created a bit of culture
like that s3 you know he was relentless
and for success just really high
standard but yeah but just you know it
was it was an environment where it was
just very successful and I think that
was a learning curve for me when I left
s3 yeah because you know I think you
kind of become accustomed to a certain
way of doing things and you're just like
oh this is what recruitment is yeah and
they even you're like she's pure
relentless work ethic yeah I mean look
naturally there's some people they're
much better on the phone
yeah and other people make up for that
by putting in more numbers and more
hours but I'd say you know that the work
ethic piece was really instilled in
everyone you know everyone that was
successful were were in earlier leaving
later you know and those were the people
that were smashing in a number of deals
a month and were you know making an
absolute ton of money so do you think
that that's the recipe for success now I
[Music]
mean look yeah there's no for me there's
no denying the fact that you know you're
never gonna get away from that you know
the harder you work the more you do the
more you're gonna get out but I think
the approach has changed and I think
society has changed yeah I guess that's
not really flexible working my old work
life balance mate no I mean you know
where some of the things that we do now
in this business
honestly I laugh about it now to my boss
cause I'm just like in mine and his day
there's never would that have happened
you know you know we might run a little
incentives to say right if we do this at
four o'clock we're gonna nip downstairs
another table tennis competition yeah
you know s3 like if you'd have said that
middle of the word you've probably got
beating with a hoodie you know so I
guess it's changed its
yeah but I think I think the world's
changed nowadays I don't think you know
there was when I was
you know recruiting contracts trying to
fill contract jobs you know staying
there till 9:00 10:00 at night sometimes
I'd send in series never getting replies
from my clients I think that's changed I
think I don't think clients are working
till that time I think everyone's a bit
more relaxed about that stuff now yeah
and it's interesting and I think for me
at the end of the day like that doesn't
mean that work ethic isn't required and
all that Juno I mean like it's it
obviously is it does have a bit of a
sort of stigma attached to it a bit now
like are you always work in all that but
I think at the end of the day like work
ethic is still so important like it's
still so important you can't you just
can't expect the sort of success that
you do want without putting in of course
not you know I mean I think that that's
sort of the the Challenger of it is
because because we're so well-connected
now it's so easy to see our cars always
on holiday and all that you'd but you
don't you don't see the stuff that led
to that I mean that that's the thing now
where I'll see you wouldn't use expose
these really big ears and you saw I
think that's why I personally really
enjoy by the documentary like the mansi
documentary stuff on yeah is it's so
easy to look at just football for
example call a centre back for man City
he's got it all right and he's getting
paid loads of money but I love ya don't
see all the work were I mean okay so
what love to go and dive into you so
goodbye what was that like I absolutely
loved it really from a lifestyle
perspective yeah I think in hindsight we
probably made a bit of a rash decision
leaving but I think that was connected
to to the personal to the professional
side of things I'm honest with you you
know there's a load of really good
people out in Dubai making an absolute
ton of money but it's very relaxed I'd
say you know if you look at all of the
big recruitment businesses across the
world you know they're middle east and
operations aren't the ones that are
making them the top dollar you know what
I mean it's just it's almost like in my
opinion that people put a business than
an office there to say we've got
presence in the Middle East you know so
and typically the the outfits there are
a bit smaller and stuff so
professionally I found it a bit of a
challenge especially going because of
what he was used to yeah well you know
what what you used to you know and it
was the first time really that had been
you know you're speaking to to clients
and candidates that you know English
isn't the first language I remember you
know hilarious story so I had come back
I'd come back for the summer once and I
was spending a week in the Manchester
office but I was working yeah it's
working like Dubai hours and I went in
there and I was finalized in putting a
an Algerian candidate into a fire in my
Algerian candidate into Qatar or
something like that whatever and you
know because you Rabin's to speak in
broken English and you know I'm
basically shouting down the phone and my
old my older hats is kind of looking at
me with a big frown on his face going
hey that sounds like hard work you know
it was completely different so I think
professionally it was it was good don't
run I enjoyed it and we did really well
but I think it was you know we was most
people are there for the lifestyle you
know whereas if you go to New York no
one goes to New York to have a jolly up
you know that there that's a graphic
because just over two years two years
mm-hmm
so how would you show it because people
thinking about going to the by doing
recruitment would they be thinking about
then I'd say getting in getting into the
right business yeah it's massively
important out there
I mean look everyone everyone out there
is doing well you know and I guess the
the difference for me was had gone from
working you know a northwestern bi
market where literally my my market was
mapped on postcodes yeah - right okay
where where s3 Dubai but we've got the
whole of the Middle East you know so we
were placing candidates into pretty much
every country out there so the UAE Oman
Qatar Kuwait and Iraq
you know so it gone from you know this
little thing to this big thing and I
think that was a challenge for me at
first because it was kind of like
you start where do you start and I'm a
massive believer that you know you more
is not always better yeah III quite like
the fact that I've got a finite list of
yeah because you kind of know you're Eva
from really double down on it you can
double down and you either either make a
success of them or you fail yeah yeah
and as simple as that whereas in Dubai
you kind of like how you've got there's
so much to go out which country do you
start in while you start there so yeah
that was those difficult but personally
lifestyle-wise yeah it was it was
unbelievable yeah yeah absolutely yeah
well obviously so so my dad's out here
and it's like I've been I've been tower
do a load so got a sort of cool
perspective of that type of culture was
a lot of people might be listening are
like war is actually like to live the
edge you know I mean as a English ya
northern lad yeah you know I mean what's
the actual culture like to there well I
think people that have never visited I
don't know much about Dubai or the
Middle East I think they they kind of
think or you know they kind of think
what they hear and see the cat got drink
you know you can't do this you can't do
that and honestly I've never drunk as
much in my life as I did when I was just
a lifestyle you know everyone out there
as an expat you know I think that really
of the population of the UAE some finish
to be like eighty percent X part really
and I'd say a large majority of that is
British or European or American so
naturally you know if they're KO into so
many expats they've got a take yeah so
it you know it was just that was the way
it was and I think is it's slightly
different from a lifestyle perspective
to New York because you know when you go
to Dubai
everyone's an xpath you know no one's
from Dubai yeah you kind of you know
forced to make friends but you're kind
of friends with the people that you work
with and you groups and your circles
just grow naturally because it's almost
like everyone's really looking for
people to kind of move around with okay
whereas when went to New York it was you
know we went there but everyone's
already lives there they've got their
own lives they're not looking to make
friends and you know stuff like that so
why do you guys need
so at left s3a moved to another business
which was a complete style I love that
experience you know literally kind of
like with my boss at the time I find in
the offices buying all the equipment and
stuff and building something that was
that was brand new that part of the
business got sold off so effectively I
got made redundant the shut down the
office and I was kind of sat there I had
a few conversations around other
opportunities in Dubai by this time I
was at a certain level and naturally you
know I guess the volume of those
opportunities was relatively slim I was
getting a lot of interest from
businesses in the UK looking to open in
Dubai and when you start something
Faro's which I was I was all for but I
kind of just I don't know I was hearing
an awful lot of really good stories
coming out of the US you know friends
that were there
20 he was this 2016 okay a lot more now
on you hundred percent yeah a bit early
on the sort of bandwagon you could say
yeah yeah I was here you know I was
having a load of good stories people out
there making good money you know it was
it was starting to I guess kind of you
know build a little bit men some people
speaking about it's the best recruitment
market in the world the natural the size
the size the country volume the fees you
know big all that type of stuff so I
kind of think I was just there wasn't a
great deal going on in Dubai if I'm
honest it kind of felt like it was felt
like it's more of a lifestyle place than
you know and I kind of felt that I was a
pie my career where I've done really
well that s3 I'd left up took a massive
leap of faith by leaving and way into
something that I absolutely loved but
you know that they kind of sold that
which wasn't ideal for me really but I
was kind of looking around I thought I'm
at a stage in my career where probably
needs a big career focused and lifestyle
focus yeah sure
and I can't from honest I kind of felt
like I had a bit of unfinished business
with the US I mean being a turf down
earlier in my life so I think there was
always a bit if I could roam romance
then you know we're going back what did
you go there to do so I went over there
and worked in a for a business that
basically is not it's not strictly exact
search but it's that model headhunting
more headhunting yeah into the life
sciences sector mainly around kind of
supply chain to life sciences yeah okay
and then having to do that for I was
there about a year okay ghost I know
what she was saying before she only went
at this point you obviously had a missus
the wife here a wife sorry before I went
to Dubai I really that's another story
so how'd that obviously I had the wife
at this point and you said yeah she
actually fell pregnant when as you went
over to or you found out she was
pregnant yeah so the day we were flying
back from Dubai to the UK to kind of
come home together isn't a stuff it was
yeah we found out she was pregnant and
you know hindsight probably should tell
us that we probably should have
reevaluated but I think you know he's
one of them you know what's the worst
that can happen all that stuff was in a
shipping container anyway just so you
know let's just go over there see what
happens go over there try you know we
never went over there we intention of
we're going to be back in - yeah I think
yeah you know the reality is that we
went out there the whole time we was
there she was pregnant so we never
really experienced the New York
lifestyle per se obviously I was out of
the house twelve hours a day you know I
felt bad she's on her own you know she
made a few friends locally but they
worked so I think she was you know spend
a lot of time on her own which I felt a
bit guilty about you know I mean like
you work in going home
you'd be thinking about work but then
they had to be present with the missus
because like that's their quality time
with huge now I mean yeah it was
difficult but I think it's one of them
things at the time you don't really
think about it too much you know we
tried to get her involved it was one it
was it was a balancing act really
because actually you know a lot of
people that go out there a lot of the
Brits were young and single you know
yeah say you're my age but they were
single yeah
they were living the life would you deny
you weren't living allowance yeah yeah
let's avoid that question no no but you
know what I mean it was kind of like I
was I had I had a wife to go home to
aniyah's pregnant and we tried to get
involved you know if there was like
company nights out yeah she was open to
that but she was obvious issue as
pregnant and the firm along she got it
would got harder and stuff like that so
and then obviously we had the baby out
there so he's got an American passport
it'll be useful later in life I'm sure
but yeah we had the baby and then again
you know I had to a couple of weeks off
paternity leave I was out the office on
the house you know 12 hours a day she
she was you know start with the newborn
our first child kind of like you know a
bit bored really I think the
conversation went a little something
like you know she was like when when the
lease runs out on this place let's let's
think about going home and I remember
just thinking well we're paying like
$4,000 a month for this place like why
would we wait another six months you
want to go home you know Esther let's do
it so let's have a pray you know awkward
conversation with my boss at the time
around like it's just you know
personally it's not working out yeah for
me and the wife and and that was that
yeah you know really enjoyed that
business some really cool people in it
to be found they do really well so
listening if you've got have many years
experience in recruitment like you
you're 100% getting absolutely spam
barrette sent American New York lived in
New York Life Specialist you're single
all that stuff right also you mentioned
about the wife
totally [ __ ] difficult clearly it was
what about socially as well because I
think that's that's something what
really consider isn't it like so for me
and when I moved out to London I I had a
really sort of friendship network at
home and moving to London I actually
luckily moved up with one one friend and
which massively house but even I think
for me what I found is like what must be
stranger than they you can relate to
this is like
couldn't even more than you but like in
London obviously it's so busy there's so
many people like you surrounded by so
many people everything with a you can
feel [ __ ] lonely yeah it is fake so
he's Frank bothers people you go to
where you see those and then like you
get homeless liar it's weird yeah do you
know I mean so like how was it socially
lie it was that good point some of my
friends and stuff like that it was a
little I think not not so much for me
because I think there was you know there
was a number of you know we had quite a
diverse cultural office really so there
were a lot of people in our office that
were over there on their own you know so
that wasn't too bad I think obviously
you know it's just the way it works over
there you know people are working late
and then going up in beers and coming in
you know so it's a it's a different way
of life but I think the social aspects
in terms of fumbling yeah so different
from Dubai because everyone's in the
same situation everyone's in expats it's
kind of looking for friends if that made
sense whereas in New York people are
kind of even even the mates that you
make when they're there they've already
been there three years they've kind of
got the wrong friends outside of that
you know so yeah you know it was
difficult in the sense that sometimes
you see you trying to you want to make
friends yeah but you know you kind of
tacking into other people's and then
obviously you got the missus oh and just
for me it was like so easy to soar make
it look amazing and all things you know
I mean I've always actually liked so I
think for me New York New York is what
you make of it you know and I think if
I'd have gone over there being a young
single radit it'd probably be a
completely different story I may even
still be there but I mean if you want
the the honest truth once once then the
novelty wears off that you live in New
York you might as well just be here I
think with the greatest respect it was
you know I think the thing people ask me
all the time
do you prefer to buy or New York and
every time I'd say to buy understand
because it's a different lifestyle it's
a way of it's a different way of living
you
what you get over there you can't get
here in the UK whereas in New York it's
just a really big say you know so it's
kind of once the novelty's worn off for
you walking down fifth after your office
and oh there's the Rockefeller once
you've kind of over that after a few
weeks it's kind of like you just did
another city you know it's very similar
to the UK in many respects yeah sure
that meant that make sense can you make
more money there like what would these
what was your experience with the fees
and all that cause obviously here all
the time now fees all that good stuff
was your experience of that yeah yes
look that there's no doubt there's the
country's bigger there's more there's
more volumes and business you know the
rolls higher paid so the seller is a
higher
yeah the fees are higher for me when I
was there I was really shocked at how
open everyone is to speak to recruit
yeah now I think you know come from a
contract background calling people in
Chester for example you know you just
you hammer in the phone just trying to
get someone to listen to you and over
there you know even if they're not
interested they'll still give you the
Internet yeah yeah this they'll still
give you the time of day to kind of say
you spiel which you know you don't
really get em here if I'm honest often
them you know so yeah I think there's
you can you can definitely make more
money there yeah so the perception of
recruiters which I've heard they're not
now it's totally different people were
open to taking a phone call these were
willing to listen
mmm-hmm it's interested me and then I
guess just just a wrap all of that up
mate wort it again if I'm listening
right now I had the opportunity to go to
New York what was I thinking about mate
so again I'd say 100 percent of the
business yes I think naturally as you'll
know there's been an absolute influx of
recruitment you a UK [ __ ] yeah it's
flowing out to the to the US for a for a
piece of the pie so I think business and
the cultural aspects of that is
massively important you know you
probably don't want to be you know if
you if you're on your own you don't
probably don't wanna be going to an All
American you know search firm where
everyone's got their own families and
lives
that'd be hundred percent something I'd
be considering and then just little
things about like where do you live like
was it so when I first went out there I
spent six weeks in a Airbnb in
Williamsburg which is Brooklyn
so unless that's kind of like supposed
to be like that you know I guess the the
Northern Quarter of Manchester like the
hippie trendy quirky place and then we
actually moved over to Hoboken which is
across the water so it's the arrests in
New Jersey okay that was a little bit
more family or insane getting bigger
space more for your money it's a way
lives key I think where you live is key
because naturally you know most people
especially the single they want to go
out there and they want to live in the
heart of it absolutely I would the
reality is is that you're probably going
to pay at least $1,000 a month to to
share an apartment with someone you know
so I mean it's it's expensive
yeah I came in and then came back and
then you've ended up at Lauren's lobby
and you've been here for how many months
now did you say 18 I've seen so how many
times have you switched industry I feel
like you've changed yeah started in
starting Tech and B I moved out to move
it out to Dubai probably about six weeks
before the oil and grab oil and gas
price crashed yeah to do Island gas so
we we kind of spun that around and did
more kind of engineering type stuff so I
guess came in again different again when
America was was life sciences different
and then back into back into tech yeah I
think what made for me and everyone
asked me this question
yes I'm like what's how have you done
that however you that's it have you
changed and I think that the answer for
me all the time is like recruitment
recruitment you know yeah you're gonna
be speaking to slightly different types
of people this you know there's
different soul nuances within each
market but the reality is is that
recruitments a process if you can nail
that and that probably I probably say
that me because I was just drilled with
process when I was you know from the s3
days you know the process for me remains
pretty consistent I think
just from having a certain element of
adaptability you know if you speak into
a vice president of a u.s.
pharmaceutical company or you know
you're speaking to I don't know French
electrical engineer who works under
yadgiri in here in your case you know
he's kind of is where it is you know you
speaking to different people you just
need to be able to guess adapt to that
situation and just and how to get on a
level for it okay how many people do you
manage so we've got a team of five at
the minute okay
it's a few things made before we get and
get to the end firstly have you done
have you done Billings wise man in your
career Billings rise yeah good mate so I
think I was I was I was looking cause so
I got s three my contract book kind of
topped out about 8k a week yes you know
is all right Pisan I guess certainly you
know I wasn't up there with some of the
top top pillars but I guess it was at
that point that I moved over to Dubai so
I had a I was pretty lucky that I still
had a contract but running in the UK who
them in tech and then I could build a
new contract book again you know so I
think I got to about 6k with that so you
know be looking at on paper and it's 14
grand a week contract book that's pretty
good going if I'm being honest most
people don't have the opportunity to do
that across to Brunn's into industries
you know so what I've ever gotten to 14
grand a week in tech doing what I was
doing mmm probably not sure what about
more recently than like because are you
still billing I'm still billing yes so I
think we've had a bit of a change in
strategy really so you know I love the
beady element of it yeah I feel really
close very client focused obviously I'm
a contract background so the candidate
piece is probably more of a challenge
for me really lost less so we do do
splits I guess that the strategy when I
first came in was look I'll go and win
as much work as we need looking we can
take the land I'll you know I'll dished
out to the team and the business making
money I'm making money they're making
money everyone's happy I guess that that
work to an extent but I guess we're at a
point now where we've if I'm honest we
probably too much work
we've run so I've been much more hands
hands-on active back in that space again
so we had a tough starts of the year you
know I think we had started we started
the Lawrence Ave last summer you know
I'm so the first you know again we
didn't do a deal so a brand new market
brand new geography and do a deal till
month four or five yeah you know so even
though I'm inexperienced you've got you
know still takes time I think that's one
thing I always say with people is hold
your nerve you know I think people are
very quick to are there is no market
here and move on is there is a market
you just need to establish yourself a
little bit so so I guess the first six
months were very much around building a
bit of a reputation for ourselves
naturally we started to increase
headcount so over time that's you know
this year has been will slow at the
start q3 we had a record record quarter
Billings wise this year's been very good
so a couple of big kind of big deals big
retained deals come off for me life's
trying to get involved in some retain
site projects have you found that
interesting
mmm how do you have you position that
like why you know I mean cuz like that's
definitely gonna be more people are
gonna be wanting to do more of that so I
think it's down it's down to the the
market that you work a lot of the time
but you know I guess what we've got in
Manchester in terms of data you know so
we typically place data scientists and
engineers data architects commanders
three are then some kind of more senior
heads on type roles and I guess we've
been quite selective in the clients that
we want to go and work with because to
be honest with you there's more there's
more demand than there is supply yeah we
didn't want to spread ourselves too thin
across too many assorted relationships
in the day if you've got a decent data
scientist you're gonna be able to place
and to be on I submit that the market is
so buoyant here at the moment for that
you know it's we get a good candidate
with components at three or four clients
will get three or four interviews will
probably get three or four offers you
know so it's it's kind of like it's
almost counterintuitive to have more
clients you know so yourself and we've
been trying to get in with businesses
that are on I guess the star of a
trajectory
have build-in a day at scene from
scratch or with that we've had a few
good good wins with that and just kind
of position it as look you know we're
especially they are data science
recruitment business that's all we focus
on here on the ground in Manchester and
we know our stuff and we know the market
you know so and that's kind of goes most
of the way if I'm being honest and yeah
you know the few businesses that were
working with now where the building
teams from scratch and they pay us like
a monthly retainer we know we understand
the challenges of common building the
team and obviously the the problem that
we can solve is that you can have a
dedicated dedicated resource that's
gonna build this team understand your
culture blah blah blah and I guess it's
something obviously there's still
expectations you got here you should
challenging but that means in that
person that's giving you an X retaining
per month means that all that team's
that's that's sorted if that makes sense
yeah absolutely
yeah that's interesting yeah I mean this
one example you know they're a
relatively new business a text up if you
will you know the hiring across the
board they've got their own internal
recruitment same as you'd expect but
they're hiring for everything a criminal
or business you know so they just
present to focus yeah exactly and
especially when it's such a candidate
driven market and it's you know most of
what we do is going head I mean
candidates because no one's really
actively looking they don't need to be
looking because they're getting
contacted 1015 times a day by recruiters
I'm sure so you know for as it was just
a case of look you you gotta trust us
with this you know and you get more or
by operating on a retained project time
model get more dedicated result or
dedicated you know you can get first
first dibs and all candidates you know
because on a contingent model yet don't
worry I'll send the candidates here but
I'm also saying you know two or three of
the clients and stuff like that yeah
okay interested in two things me
mmm-hmm I'm thinking about which I think
people want to know more about you so
you sound like a business development
machine thing I might be stretching
email you sort of say off the cuff like
six-month did make a deal really before
I'll get in the work blah blah blah you
know I mean so lied now you're managing
people stuff like that use mention
process
you mentioned about your experience and
also you haven't having the events
that's really helped but I guess just to
just to sort of give it like yeah I
guess just finalize some key pointers on
that like the business development piece
like was what sort of processes of you
helped sort of implement in your team
and stuff like that that you think of
brought their more success which is work
for you you know I mean what what does
some of these processes look like just
because I think me like well it's been a
journey with light you know I mean
anything just to wrap that up it seems
like you just done really well with that
and I think that's what a lot of people
struggle yeah so I think you know we've
we've had a focus on these events
because they've been a success and even
now when I'm speaking to clients about
them quite quite honest in the fact that
it's probably snowballed into something
bigger than I ever thought I'd be so
like you know we have people that are
based in the team that focused on a
specific geography for example you know
so I've said look go and have the same
conversation is just like replicate that
home that whole event piece because
naturally you know it obviously works
yeah clients are interested in speaking
to you about it because it's slightly
different
I think that's if there's anything that
I'd say nowadays is I say to the guys
all the time and it's a bit cheesy but
you know about kind of trying to be a
celebrity in your market yeah not like
you know David Beckham celebrities but
you know just just be someone that
people know because I think that for me
that's I've had so many referrals in
introduction because I'm in my next
thing what's actual pendant why should
recruit to be aiming for that yeah so I
think you know there's so many referrals
introductions I mean we held our fourth
event of what's might become a series
world and our fifth one at the end of
the month up in Edinburgh but I was
looking around the room and we held it
last week and I think as recruiters
people loft and you know were
salespeople right so there's there's an
element of you know you want to get
something back from every single thing
in terms of the tangible result yeah and
I think what I've realized is that you
know our sat around the room and I was
looking there was there was 18 people
around that room and there was probably
only four or five of them that are
actually our clients and you know but
all
rest of them I'd like to think you know
if we went to them or someone
independent went to them and said who
who was a go-to day a recruiter in
Manchester why do you think they'd
probably say oh yeah because of that so
it's not always about getting the
tangible result there and then I'm
pretty confident the further down the
line that were things they'll open up
for us I think yeah and if you're
serious about the events you can't just
have that mindset because it will mean
that some of the decisions you'll be
more prone to making your decisions that
in the events not as gray that hasn't
made you more money absolutely yeah
I mean that to be honest we think that
that's been our our kind of soul
singular strategy it's a sense of
putting putting deals around the board
because so many there'll be so many
people yeah that make the assumption
that now events have been done too many
of them do you know I mean sorry I'm
just I think I think that's wicked mate
then that's happened and so many people
make the assumption that you can't make
money out of it because everyone's done
it and the only thing I just wanted to
I'd love to get you around for something
again clearly showing it throughout your
career again you said about give it
enough time in terms of the marketing
stuff like that I think you said earlier
on around light it just saw who you are
in the way you're made but I'm just even
now you having to cut a bit more
resilience in your people and tell them
to be patient and these lots of things
yeah like how what's your journey been
like with resilience and however you've
got better at cultivating that in
yourself but also your team I think I
think for me that has just come
naturally that's more of a
characteristic of me as a person but
yeah look I think that's that's a
challenge for a lot of recruiters you
know especially I think what what is the
challenge is you know naturally we've
got people in our office for example
that they're all at different levels and
so you know you've got someone sat there
that might have been in the business
three or four months they're very
talented they're doing all the right
things they're not seeing results and
they look across the room and someone
may be working inside a different market
who's getting a lot of results
especially quite a small environment
it's it's quiet yeah it's tough to say
that it's funny because I was thinking
about this the other day it was kind of
like you know you you
you were kind of told and trained s3 the
markets irrelevant the market doesn't
matter you know if it's failing it's
because of you and I think you know
there's a certain element of that but I
think for me it's like I said before I
you've got a holy nerve with stuff but
in terms of resilience I don't even when
I joined Laurence Harvey now I'm six
months in we'd only done a couple of
placements in day and I'm sat there you
know I'm speaking to my boss and trying
to justify what what we're doing and
even then I'm kind of saying to it yeah
I'm saying soon I'll be honest now I'm
kind of on the fence here and he was
saying like look just keep doing what
you're doing you know if you feel that
there's a market that is a market there
you just got that you do that things
helps with that or not I don't know is
anything that you do on a daily basis
that besides also dressing like guns
black poor like anything that you other
no just out of interest is anything that
what we've resilience yeah just like
anything that you become like a bit of a
daily practice that you do or anything
I'm not really I don't think it's a
conscious thing weren't really a fair
just for that that might be interesting
if you had any personally for me I don't
think it's a conscious thing I think
it's I think it's become a conscious
thing for me from a management
perspective yes Ryan encouraged others
it was currently in yeah you know and I
think that to be honest with you one of
my biggest flaws is that that's just not
my person I would say no so that's
something that I've had to work on
extremely hard over the years you know
if someone makes a good call you know me
five years ago my [ __ ] job you know I
probably learned how to manage people in
completely the wrong way through trial
and error i given the opportunity s3 to
manage people because it's kind of like
you know I was I was doing really well I
was I was getting myself into that crowd
of top billa's within the office and it
was kind of like you know if people kind
of said well why do we do this and it
was come on cuz I just told you to
because it works obviously yeah yeah you
know whereas obviously now it's kind of
just relaying
the benefits to them and encourage you
know that yeah you know that call that
cause wicked but this in specific this
what you said there make sure you do
that again and again and again and
whatever you just had to actually go on
that journey or view had some help with
that or understand her doubt without
obviously we do like management courses
you have been on stuff and you know I'd
say that's certainly not a kind of
natural strength of mine violence about
to work on work on trains have that at
the front of my mind you know I think
it's difficult sometimes because I'm you
know I'm still their hands-on hands-on
you know you know headphone on speaking
to clients and stuff so it is difficult
so kind of be understanding everything
that's going on around us but how do you
structure your day to enable that you
can spin all these plates and keep on
top of them so obviously we do kind of
you know daily plans if I think it's
about understanding that the team know
what they're doing but for us we like to
try and give them as much autonomy as
possible you know we kind of say look
we're here for as much guidance and
support as you need you know but make
sure if you need it you ask us you know
don't just sit there kind of failing if
you have to get better out a lot of
people who said before and the
management piece where like they had to
make it we're like I if I'm in your team
right now that I can just come up to you
and disrupt your day at any point even
though it's probably something I could
work out myself like we had to get I
don't know if you've done anything when
it's live between 12:00 and 1:00 you can
ask me and I'll give you my fault yeah
unless it's like really important you
know I mean I think I think that depends
on the environment you're in and where
where you're up where you're up to as a
business at that level because I think
naturally we've got you know quite a few
people that are still very inexperienced
yeah for me at this point is okay so
look I'd rather you come and ask me and
directs you know if it if you need
something corrects and I can do it now
as opposed to you spending two hours
doing something in the wrong direction
yeah but obviously prior where I've
managed teams of experienced people you
know yeah there's been times like look
unless it's business critical I'm
involved in something yeah I guess to
the point where often you know a look
could kill you know can I get aa you
know
I think I've I've gotten more relaxed
and you know the more experienced I've
got think I've just probably an awful
lot as well so as we finished my I think
you you through your experiences in the
different types of things you've seen in
your career like what what do you think
recruiters now I have to do to to stay
relevant obviously you mentioned about
being this lemons in your market and
stuff but like how do you see this plan
analogy no I mean how do you see your
you and your guys stem relevant in your
market over the next five to ten years
so I think I think recruitment did this
cycles right I think that that's always
going to happen but I think you know
being able to to build a bit of a
personal brand
you know network relationships I think
for me it's just about I say to the guys
all the time look we're sitting down
this afternoon to go through like a
client strategy piece yeah I'm I'm
probably guilty of being too involved in
that type of strategic stuff for quite
like that right who we going after why
we're going after you know we're gonna
do it I'm gonna engage them how are we
gonna be different yeah but I think
that's for me that's what's worked so I
guess that's that's where you know I try
to pass my experience on but I think you
know to answer your question it's about
how do you how do you stand out from the
ground because this there's so much
noise you know eventually in the tech my
yeah I mean what every technical crew at
now is you know they've they've added
date are on or something else they do
and and naturally why wouldn't you
there's a massive market for it but you
know so for me it's around well how do
we keep getting that message out that
this is this is just what we do yeah and
we're really specialists at it and I
think obviously the events have helped
position us as I guess that authority
figure to a certain extent but you know
there's there's so much more stuff that
we can be doing hence why we spoke in
the first place right
okay cool was having that voice being
asking people recent just cuz I've got a
lot of message about it recently and
then I ask you the final question may
what and counteroffers
what's been your experience in the last
12 months has there been more of those
have you been experiencing more of those
as a team because I've got loads of
messages about it recently
everyone I've asked they've said you
know what they'd definitely be more
prevalent well yeah what have you had
any experiences that you sort of know
still picked up on that there's been
more or I think I think they're there as
yeah thinking about it there probably
has been a little bit more but again I
think for for me that just goes down to
being very meticulous about the process
so we address that like they don't know
when we're speaking so we're out you've
gone interview Watson okay look if this
goes well what do you reckon the chances
are getting a counteroffer
okay well would that need to look like
something specific than you to consider
it you know so we we try to address that
very early but I'd say most of the deals
we've done actually you do get cancer
think you I think it depends on the
market obviously our sister brand our
Harrison they work in the real estate
and property space you know qsr and
commercial type stuff it seems to be
very prevalent yeah voice I've said it's
a few times that I was like yeah but
candidate 8% of people there yeah yeah
yeah I mean you've got a lush feel and
you know anything but a lot of people
said it's like you need to really like
really address that early on first
conversation have you spoken have you
spoken internally mmm-hmm what could
they do to is anything they could do to
make you stay a blah blah blah because
sometimes you can't do anything about it
but I guess it's a matter of you being
answer look in the mirror and go was I'm
meticulous is that did ask the right
questions or not yeah advice then I mean
that's my advice but you know you can
say everything that you need to say and
you've been trained to say when you get
to that point if you trying to battle
the counteroffer at that you know at the
twelfth hour but I think you know if
you've tried to mitigate as much risk as
you can
prior to that happening then it's less
likely to happen yes
but yeah I think for us that's one of
the reasons why we tried to work with
certain types of clients that probably
got a bit more of a cooler compelling
story they didn't a cool stuff you know
so it's kind of like what they you work
in a company X company err doing this
yeah yeah I think as well when you've
got that type of sort of retained
relationship or you've got that
relationship crying that's something you
should be communicating to them that
look cut offers are becoming more
prevalent at the moment this isn't just
down to me to prevent that we'll make
sure that they understand yeah you know
I mean I'm sure that's all set down to
the sort of communication in relation
and Brian to say look how can we work
together to ensure that we're giving the
most competitive or the most appetizing
offer for these people absolutely I mean
I think that's you know when you get
into those types of relationships where
you know people are paying you for a
service before you've even delivered
that service you doing as cheesy as it
sounds you do almost become like an
extension of that they take you and they
take your advice see really you know so
we've had instances where you know
feedback has been slower than we need it
to be and you know I've been able to go
in there and say look you already paid
us for this you know so I'm only trying
to help you but here's what you need to
do to be able to you know attract better
talent the best cause if you're going to
take X amount of time to come back on
feedback on the series or the interviews
the reality is is you've got competition
in the market the a wrap in three stage
interviews I've been inside a week with
an offer and this is an experience that
you're given a candidate that's what's
not beneficials a nice mate so were you
excited about mate before we finish
what's going on and clearly an event
organizer yeah so we obviously from a
business perspective we've got another
event up in Edinburgh I am which one of
my teams actually kind of run and cited
only so that's that's been pretty cool
to see always up in any brother in the
week kind of points it like that it's
really got you to where new guns
Blackpool we're going to Blackpool so
the 6th of December buzzing yeah
what else even what you guys hiring or
what what scrap yeah hiring yeah the
minute so I mean we were on now what are
for this our fourth office in twelve
months so you know we work yeah so but
we've moved around so as in spinning
fields didn't have room for us there to
move so we went to Saint Peter's Square
and yeah it's what twice in there and
then to here so we work the naughty
wears often at yeah it does I think the
office space is nice yeah it's it's
certainly an element of attraction to to
especially more junior people that
coming in you know when you're telling
them that you get your morning coffee
and your beers free you know it's
faithlyn's probably it adds an extra
five grand onto the side right question
always ask people to finish this off
mate is if you could communicate to
every recruiter out there they'd listen
to advice they take it on it could be a
phrase sentence what springs to mind
mate if you could if car could get into
the minds of mate I think that's
probably changed over time but if if
there's one thing that I would say now
to any any recruiter that's long
listening is think about how you're
trying to stand out and be different and
be celebrity come back to buy cars been
a pleasure to know president